[Música]
actualizamos las noticias de la economía
con Juan Pablo luco y Juan Pablo saludo
para usted nuevamente aquí estamos
nuevamente y vamos a hablar de las
previsiones globales del FM y hay buenas
noticias Pues en general sí aunque
inicialmente vamos a ver el gráfico pues
unas proyecciones bajas y se compara con
las de 2022 de forma general Ángela el
fmi aumentó sus previsiones para 2023 y
espera una recuperación mayor para 2024
Y eso es lo que vemos a continuación
para la economía Global en un 2,9 esto
en un aumento de dos décimas de la que
de la provisión que había hecho en
Octubre y para 2024 ya uno casi cerca de
la del 2022 para las economías avanzadas
estamos hablando Pues de Europa de
Estados Unidos y algunas de Asia también
una previsión del 1,2 y para el 2024
también una mejora incluso Pero todavía
no se acerca a las pre pandémicas y para
mercados emergentes y economías en
desarrollo que es donde nos involucran a
nosotros a latinoamérica y demás si hay
una una mejora usted que hay una décima
mayor que pues la de 2022 y para 2024
incluso mucho mejor así que el panorama
es bueno y veremos también a
continuación una lista de en general
Cuáles han sido esos aumentos en las
décimas que pues han proyectado y lo
veremos a continuación Un aumento de
ocho décimas para la provisión de China
mire si usted puede ver todos es un
aumento me preguntaba si hay buenas
noticias y en general sí cuatro décimas
para Estados Unidos dos décimas también
en aumento para la previsión global dos
décimas para el crecimiento de la
eurozona que ya veremos algunos datos
también de esta región y una décima para
América Latina y el Caribe Aunque parece
que es muy poco para América Latina
también pues usted puede ver que
alcanzaremos el 4,2 incluso para 2023
Pero escuchemos qué fue lo que dijo el
fondo monetario internacional con este
informe
se espera que la economía mundial se
ralentiza este año antes de repuntar El
próximo el crecimiento seguirá siendo
débil en términos históricos ya que la
lucha contra la inflación y la guerra en
Rusia en Ucrania pesan sobre la
actividad a pesar de estos vientos en
contra las perspectivas son menos
sombrías que en nuestras previsiones de
octubre y podrían representar un punto
de inflexión con un crecimiento que
toque fondo y una inflación en descenso
el crecimiento económico se mostró
sorprendentemente resistente en el
tercer trimestre del año pasado con un
mercado laboral fuerte una demanda
privada robusta y una adaptación a la
crisis energética en Europa mejor de lo
esperado vamos a cambiar de tema vamos a
hablar de lo que ha pasado
específicamente con la economía del
Reino Unido hoy que son tres años del
brexit un tema que hemos tenido
recurrentemente a lo largo de toda
nuestra franja Así es Ángela Pues yo le
cuento que la queja de muchos en esos
países que aún no se han beneficiado de
los dividendos del brexit que se
prometieron para la economía Pues
británica en 2022 el entonces Primer
Ministro Boris Johnson prometió que iba
a desarrollar su potencial económico
pero hasta hoy sucede lo contrario ya
que varios indicadores muestran un
rendimiento inferior al de otras
economías la situación actual se resume
en una crisis por la inflación anual más
alta en 40 años sin mencionar la tasa
histórica que alcanzó también de forma
anual en octubre cuando llegó al 11,1
por ciento y desde entonces pues podemos
ver que aunque ha venido a la baja sigue
todavía pues muy alta hace falta también
muchos trabajadores en sectores como
salud y atención social así como el
sector ferroviario enfermeros empleados
del servicio de ambulancias maestros
entre otros qué dicen entonces los
empresarios algunos centros de
pensamiento y organismos independientes
revelan que la economía británica
británica creció un 5,5% menos en 2022
por la salida del bloque europeo el
siete por ciento de las empresas admiten
que el brexit no les ayuda a expandir su
negocio y el 44% de las empresas
reportan dificultades para avisados
personal otro sector afectado fue
laboral ya que la salida de la Unión
Europea también supuso cambios en las
normas sobre las libre circulación de
trabajadores con la salida del Reino
Unido del mercado único y la unión
aduanera en 2021 las empresas que
comercian con los 27 enfrentan pues
nuevas normas nuevos trámites y nuevos
controles en algunas mercancías al
principio se produjo un descenso de las
exportaciones británicas al bloque
europeo pero una vez resuelto los
problemas iniciales los volúmenes
comerciales recuperaron los niveles
prepandemia según las cifras oficiales
sin embargo algunos analistas dicen que
el comercio pudo crecer mucho más
recientemente la cámara de comercio
británica en cuestión a quinientas
empresas más de la mitad dijo que
todavía estaba lidiando con el nuevo
sistema y más datos hoy también salieron
a los informes pre de cómo les fue a las
economías europeas en el año 2022 Así es
la primera estimación preliminar de este
año la segunda la revisaremos Ángela el
14 de febrero ya veremos si estaremos
aquí para revisarla también y esto lo
haremos con base a los últimos datos del
trimestre del 2022 estamos hablando
entre octubre y diciembre Comparado con
Julio a septiembre también y lo podemos
ver en el siguiente mapa podemos ver que
una la principal economía de Europa Tuvo
una contracción del 0,2% y esto en
contraste con Francia que sí mejoró Y
tuvo un 0,1% la principal o la ganadora
de estos datos fue Irlanda con el 3,5%
en su pib eso en este trimestre y otras
que también tuvieron como un revés fue
el caso de Italia y de Austria de manera
general la zona Euro tuvo un avance de
un 0,1% y la Unión Europea se mantuvo
básicamente igual con esto podemos decir
que están esquivando la recesión Y para
dónde se pensaba ver el 14 de febrero No
pues es una fecha especial Pero
esperemos que estemos aquí es lo que yo
digo solamente bueno Juan Pablo después
de ese secreto suyo con los informes del
14 de febrero hablemos de los
indicadores Bueno vamos directamente a
Asia el cierre en esta región se dio
negativo eso sin conocer el informe del
fmi en el que aumentó 8 décimas el
crecimiento de china en 2023 tras el
final de la política cero covid las
bolsas en Europa siguen operando en
terreno negativo con los reportes del
fmi a su favor pues le agradezco mucho
Juan Pablo ya se puede ir a descansar
tranquilamente a tomarse su buen
desayuno y nos vemos mañana nos vemos
mañana con más